HUESO.
HERE HUESO HERE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE HERE BRADFORD.
RED HAIRED CHANGE.
KING HERE DIED.
DIED HERE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HERE HE'LL.
KILL HERE FIRE.
MCGUIRE HERE RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE SKINNER.
STERN.
DOWN STONE'S THERE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ON BEHALF OF MY LAKE CLIENT I'M
GONNA STEP IN ON HIS BEHALF.
AND I'M PRESENTING SB -- SEVEN
SIXTY SIX AS THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ARE KEENLY AWARE OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS WE'VE
TAKEN EXTRAORDINARY STRIDES AND
SMART ENERGY MANAGEMENT AND
WATER CONSERVATION.
THIS MEASURE -- THE REPRESENTS
STEP TWO FOOT ISSUES REGULATIONS
ARE BY THE WAY.
THAT TO TO TO FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES ARE HE IS SIMPLE CHANGES
BUT I NEVER USE THE WORD SIMPLE
AND LEGISLATION OTHERWISE I'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYBODY A PRESS
RELEASE USE WORDS SIMPLE. TWO
VERY IMPORTANT CHANGES
MEANINGFUL CHANGES FIRST.
THE BILL ALIGNS WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM GUIDELINES -- FOR
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES AND
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
ALLOWING PUBLIC YOUR OWN
UTILITIES TO IMPLEMENT NEW
ENERGY MANAGEMENT TECHNOLOGIES
FOR LOW INCOME CONSUMERS SECOND.
THE BILL GIVES US -- THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
PUBLIC OWNED UTILITIES A NEW
TOOL TO GET IT TO CONSIDER IN
WEATHER'S ATION PROGRAMS --
WATER CONSERVATION MEASURES THAT
RESULT IN SAVINGS.
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS MEASURE
FURTHER INVESTORS ARE SUCCESSFUL
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM OF FROM WHICH NIGHT TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DEPLOYED ONE
HUNDRED NINETY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. TO SERVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS BY APPARENTLY MORE
THAN TWO AND FIFTY THOUSAND
METRIC TONS.
ON SO WITH THAT I WILL GIVE YOU
ANDREA DIVO BUT TO US TO TALK
ABOUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
I CAN MORNING AT YOUR HUESO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDREA DIVO I AM HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF RECON DYNAMICS.
A TECH COMPANY THAT STANDS AT
THE NEXUS OF TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
AND MODERNIZATION PROVIDING
ASSET TRACKING TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ENABLE UTILITY COMPANIES TO
OPERATE MORE EFFICIENTLY.
RECON DYNAMICS IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SEVEN SIX
SIX THREE THANK SENATOR STERN
AND NOW SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS MEASURE.
I SENATE BILL SEVEN SIX SIX IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL OPEN
THE DOOR FOR THE STATE TO
LEVERAGE ABOUT THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAMS. TO ALSO
YOU UTILIZE WATER EFFICIENT
TECHNOLOGIES TO INCREASE ENERGY
SAVINGS.
AS CALIFORNIA'S STRIVES TO
DEPLOY ENERGY AND WATER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS LIKE THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
UTILITY COMPANIES WILL PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING
THOSE MEASURES AND RECON
DYNAMICS IS READY TO HELP
SUPPORT THE ACHIEVEMENT.
OF THOSE GOALS SET FORTH IN THE
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS THANK YOU
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
AFTER I VOTE THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS IN THE AUDIENCE WILL
YOU SPEAK AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION.
ANY SPEAKERS [inaudible]
ANY COMMENTS.
CHEN I'D LIKE TO IF I COULD
OFFER A FRIENDLY AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD BE OKAY THAT THIS THAT
BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THIS MORNING THIS BILL APPLIES
TO ALL JURISDICTIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA EXCEPT.
A CENTER STERN SENATORIAL
DISTRICT [inaudible]
READ THROUGH.
I'M I'M STILL AT A LOSS TO WHAT
THE BILL ACTUALLY DOES SO CAN --
TO ONE NUMERATOR.
SO I'M IT WILL IMPROVE WEATHER
IS ASIAN PROGRAMS -- IT DIRECTS
THE CC AND THE AND THE PC TO
CONSIDER COST EFFECTIVENESS WHEN
CONSIDERING THE IMPLANTATION OF
WEATHER IS ATION MEASURES -- AND
LOW INCOME DWELLINGS IT'S AN
EXTENSION OF THE OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAM I UNDERSTAND BUT POR
FOLKS JUST IN THE NATURE BEEN
POOR ALWAYS CONSERVE WATER --
THEY HAVE A LOWER USAGE IN THE
STATE SO I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE EXPANDING APART?
IS THERE A PENALTY IF THEY DON'T
SAY.
YEAH THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S NO
PENALTY IT'S MORE OF A SORT OF
COMMUNICATIONS WITH BUSINESSES
SMART METERS WHICH THEY ALREADY
HAVE INSTALLED TOGETHER TO ALLOW
THEM.
TO SO THIS IS START INSTALLING
SMART METERS AND THESE LOW
INCOME.
THE SMART METERS RD AND SIT IN
THE BILL ALSO SAYS INCLUDES
ATTIC INSULATION CAULKING
WEATHER STRIPPING.
LOW FLOW SHOWERHEADS WATER
HEADLINE WATER HEATER BLANKETS
DOOR AND BUILDING ENVELOPE
REPAIRS WHICH REDUCE AIR THAT ON
FOR THE THOSE VARIOUS FACTORS.
THANK YOU OF SIR MORE LIKE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D I'D TO A
LITTLE CONFUSED SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS -- YOU MENTION WATER
EFFICIENCY TECHNOLOGIES TO
REDUCE REDUCE ENERGY AND YOU
MENTIONED LOW FLOW SHOWERHEADS.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS WATER CONSERVATION
MEASURES THAT RESULT IN ENERGY
SAVINGS.
WE'LL BE LIKE A NEW WATER HEATER
THAT USES LESS ELECTRICITY YOUR
YES I'VE JUST EVERYTHING WHAT
EVERYTHING MOVING WATER IS IS IT
THERE'S A CORRELATION DIRECT
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE TWO THE
ECHO ENERGY COSTS ROSE TO THE
CALIFORNIA MOVE WATERS
EXTRAORDINARY.
SO THE STATE YOU CAN CONSERVE
WATER CONSERVE ENERGY THERE'S A
NEXUS BETWEEN THE TWO NOT JUST
WITH RESPECT TO MOVING WATER
FROM THE NORTH TO THE SOUTH.
OR FROM TWO US SOLVENCY.
HOURS OF TALK OF THE CITY BUT
BUT IT ALSO.
IT IS A CORRELATION SO THE MORE
YOU CAN SAY WATER THE MORE YOU
SAVE ENERGY.
THEN HOW DOES THAT HELP.
IN THE CASES CENTER BRADFORD'S.
LINE OF QUESTIONING ARE WE
GIVING NEW WATER HEATERS.
TO NOT WHAT WOULD I WORK WE
COULD INSTALL PROJECTS THAT HAVE
SOLAR HEATERS TO WATER THAT
WOULD ELIMINATE THE USE OF GAS
FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW IF THERE
WAS A WILL [inaudible]
BUT AND AND THAT IS IN THE AREA
OF ENERGY CONSERVATION AS AN
EXAMPLE.
I JUST DIDN'T SEE HOW WATER
CONSERVATION COULD MEAN
INSTALLING.
LOWER FLUSH TOILETS NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALLOWS SAVINGS
AND WATER IN THE WAY.
SHOWERS OPERATE THE WAY TOILETS
OPERATE SINKS EVERYTHING ELSE.
SODEXHO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF MANY.
I WOULD.
GO OKAY.
OKAY WE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
CENTER MCGUIRE CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SB SEVEN SIX SIXTY PASSED TO THE
FLOOR WAS SO I WAS SO I MORE
LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE BRADFORD AYE DODD --
DOT AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STERN.
DOWN DOWN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
THE BILL IS A WELL WITH US
TURNOUT VOTING FOR HIS OWN BILL
WE ARE